من جانبه قال وزير الامن القومي
الاسرائيليه تمار بن كفير ان على الاداره
الامريكيه برئاسه بايدن ان تتوقف عن الضغط
على اسرائيل بشان ادخال الوقود لحماس
واضاف ان اسرائيل تدخل مساعدات انسانيه
فقط الى غزه حسب
تعبيره هناك مشكله في تعامل المجلس المصغر
مع النظام الامريكي لا يهمني كم سيهاجمون
ني في الاعلام ولاكم يهاجمني مستشار رئيس
الحكومه فالجمهور يفهم ما المشكله نحن نحب
امريكا ونقدر النظام ولكن يجب تغيير طريقه
العمل وقول هذه الامور لا يوجد لدي مكناسه
ولن اكنس الواقع المعقد مع نظام بايدن تحت
الطاوله امريكا صديقتنا وحليفتها ولكن
نظام بايدن يجب ان يتوقف عن الضغط علينا
بان ندخل الوقود لحماس نحن ندخل مساعدات
انسانيه
فقط